oMG it totally makes sense some things
in Disney frozen might seem weird or
even impossible but when you break it
all down these things make perfect sense
here are 10 of the weirdest things in
frozen explained watch until the end to
find out about Elsa's new powers in
frozen 2 here we go
Elsa's dress that moment when Elsa sings
her epic song let it go while
transforming into her new Ice Queen gown
is everything whoa
so is it weird that Elsa has magic
fashion powers in addition to her ice
powers not in the Disney princess realm
in fact fashion transformations are kind
of a thing with Disney Princesses look
at Cinderella she went from rags to
ballgown in a very similar way it seems
that else I used her frost powers to
create a special sort of ice fabric
maybe she magically weaved together icy
threads to create that magnificent gown
that would explain the sparkles the
trolls frozen has no shortage of magic
history and mythology from Elsa's ice
powers to the mysterious way her powers
are connected to her emotions to the
mythological element of the trolls
issues
it seems like a whole lot of
make-believe but the trolls in the movie
actually came from actual Nordic legends
that's right according to Norse
mythology cave trolls live underground
it seems that all mythological creatures
may be grounded in reality to some
extent with all the undiscovered wonders
on planet Earth who's to say there
aren't Little Rock trolls screwing
around somewhere out there after all
they have some pretty sneaky camouflage
their rocks this sudden engagement you
got engaged to someone you just met that
day yeah
oh no agreed to marry hunts after
knowing him for just a few hours but you
can't really blame her she had been
cooped up in the castle for most of her
formative years she never got the chance
to develop crucial social skills and had
to only heard about relationships and
fairytale books what if I meet someone
knowing this her rash engagement
suddenly makes perfect sense
Anna was so naive and excited about
falling in love that she refused to see
any of the red flags spending 18 years
in solitude can do that to a person this
fixer-upper and who's the funky-looking
donkey over there
Kristoff isn't exactly a knight in
shining armor he talks to and shares
slobbery carrots with his reindeer he
talks about nose picking and he snarky
and strange he's a prince all men do it
you get so now he's perfect for Anna but
if you think about it his bizarre
behavior makes total sense he was
adopted by rock trolls after being
abandoned by his family I don't want to
scare you they can be a little
inappropriate and spend what's his only
friend in fact it seems that Sven is
more like a brother to Kristoff than a
pet
he didn't benefit from etiquette
training in a big castle he only had his
troll family and his reindeer so while
he is a bit of a fixer-upper he's a
great adventure buddy beware the Frozen
Heart the trolls once warned on his
parents that a frozen heart could
catastrophic yet somehow else's love
managed to thaw out on his heart against
all odds this isn't exactly impossible
when you think about it in fact honest
symptoms could all be explained by a
medical condition called hypothermia
hypothermia occurs when the body
experiences dangerously low temperatures
which on it was subjected to in the
mountains so while it might have been
sisterly love that defrosted on his
heart it could also have been the body
heat she received when her sister gave
her a warm hug just ask Olaf warm hugs
really are the solution surviving the
eternal winter the people of arendelle
had little to no time to prepare for
Elsa's eternal winter so how did they
manage to survive well it's possible
that they received help from the
surrounding kingdoms like weaselton and
the Southern Isles oaken's trading post
probably got a lot of business during
that unexpected winter that would be in
our winter department can you imagine
all the people of arendelle packed into
its sauna to keep warm and they probably
had to pull out their winter coats and
blankets from storage maybe arendelle
treated their goods to these other lands
like flowers and carrots in exchange for
firewood and blankets or it's possible
they had extra food and resources for
the inevitable return of the winter the
kings of my barons all knows a thing or
two about heavy snowfall after all why
couldn't on it go outside in the movie
both on and Elsa were forced to stay
inside and away from the subjects of
arendelle locked the gates will reduce
the staff we know the reason that Elsa
had to stay locked in her room but what
about Anna she was so bored and lonely
without anyone to play with why didn't
they let her outside the gates of the
castle
perhaps if Anna was let outside but Elsa
remained confined inside the castle
walls people would have started asking a
lot of questions
Anna definitely didn't understand why
Elsa was being kept away there's
no way she would be able to explain it
to the people in the kingdom so maybe
that's why her parents kept them both
inside knowledge of Elsa's powers would
have caused a panic among the subjects
of arendelle similar to the one we
witnessed on Coronation day so it was
best for their parents to keep both Anna
and Elsa locked in the castle it's
coronation day my fault the gloves
Elsa's powers are magnificent and strong
so how can a pair of silk gloves be
tough enough to contain such incredible
powers
maybe Elsa's parents had the gloves
specifically made for her by the trolls
see conceit don't fear it but if the
trolls made these gloves for Elsa they
didn't take into account one crucial
detail about her powers but we'll get to
that at the end of the video another
explanation is that Elsa's dad pretended
that the gloves could stop her powers
from seeping through which created a
placebo effect the placebo effect is
strong and unexplainable proving that
the mind can manifest what it believes
to be true so while the gloves may have
seemed useless they were actually of
great importance to Elsa Olaf Elsa's
powers are so mysterious that we still
don't know how powerful she really is
however we do know that she can create
snow beings
she created two over the course of the
first movie one was our lovable pal Olaf
I don't have a skull or bones the other
was that big scary snow monster that
takes Elsa's powers to a whole new level
the only explanation is that Elsa can
create life from snow since water is a
main building block of life and snow is
made from water then that means Elsa can
controll life that would make her a
goddess rather than just a queen with
magical powers oh I've been impaled
walking on water
at first we were led to believe that
Elsa's powers emanated from her
fingertips
but after watching the frozen to trailer
we're not so sure anymore it turns out
Elsa's powers can also flow through her
feet how else would she be able to walk
on water so if the trolls did indeed
make Elsa magical gloves they should
have accounted for magical socks as well
now that the world knows about Elsa's
powers she's free to use them as she
pleases so it goes without saying that
she's been practicing since the last
time we saw her we can't wait to see how
much Elsa's powers have grown since the
original frozen film before you go let
us know if you think Anna will develop
magical powers of her own in the
upcoming sequel thanks for watching the
things if you love frozen as much as we
do then subscribe to our channel to be
the first to see our latest videos and
don't forget to click the thumbs up
button while you're at it see you next
time
[Music]